Prof: I learned over the
weekend of the death of Claude
Lévi-Strauss;
I don't know if you read it in
the paper or if you know who
Claude Lévi-Strauss was.
Claude Lévi-Strauss,
who was a hundred and one years
old when he died,
was a great French
anthropologist,
the founder of the School of
Structuralism,
though he would never admit to
that,
as truly remarkable
intellectual figure of the
twentieth century,
who traveled through the
jungles of Brazil and wrote a
number of very important
anthropological books,
and one, a memoir,
called Tristes
Tropiques,
fifty-four, fifty-five,
which is truly a beautiful,
beautiful book.
And I was very moved reading
the obituary in that he said,
at one point,
that he had learned to pursue
the truth doggedly,
and also had the idea of
reviving something from the
past,
while reading Don
Quixote as a child,
in a children's edition,
obviously translated into
French.
So I thought that I would
mention that beginning the
class, and also as an homage to
a really great figure of our
day.
I have been insisting in my
last few lectures on how
Cervantes rewrites episodes from
Part I in Part II,
and I want to begin today with
some general statements of this
theme and a few other general
statements as we approach the
end of the novel.
First, I want to make clear
that not all episodes in Part II
are modeled after others in Part
I.
There is no antecedent,
really, for the cave of
Montesinos adventure,
which is the highlight of Part
II, and perhaps of the whole
book;
nor is there really an
antecedent for the
Clavileño flight,
so there are a number of
important episodes in Part II
that are not modeled on episodes
from Part I.
You will get to see,
as I announced,
episodes in Part II that repeat
or rewrite episodes within Part
II itself, which is very
interesting.
Second, I want to emphasize
that the rewritings are
expansions of those episodes in
Part I;
they are like blowups,
one could say,
of episodes in Part I;
they tend to have more
characters, and the actions are
outrageous in comparison to
their predecessors.
For instance,
there is something of the fight
with the Basque in Don Quixote's
encounter with Sansón
Carrasco disguised as the Knight
of the Mirrors,
but the second episode is
richer.
In the first,
they are both mounted,
armed, and Don Quixote wins.
The same occurs in the second,
but now his opponent is playing
the role of a knight.
His outfit reflects Don
Quixote, literally and
metaphorically,
and the whole set up is
carefully prepared to resemble a
contest between two knights,
though none of this is present
in the earlier episode.
This expansion or enlargement
is consonant with the
increasingly Baroque aesthetics
of Part II,
and each instance of a
rewriting is like one more proof
of it,
one more proof of this Baroque
aesthetics.
Cervantes has not remained the
same in the ten years that have
elapsed between Parts I and II,
and the old Cervantes is his
own measure of development,
as it were.
I don't know if I make myself
clear;
that is, the Cervantes of Part
I is the measure for his new
sense of development.
In the episodes that I will be
discussing today and in
subsequent lectures,
this process of expansion is
itself expanded,
reaching the limits of
representation,
which is, again,
also a characteristic of the
Baroque.
I also want to insist on
something that I have only
hinted at in previous lectures,
and that you may have noticed
on your own: the increasing
presence of Virgil and his
Aeneid as we move towards
the end of the second part of
the Quixote.
I will be more specific about
this when we get to meet
Altisidora,
whom you may have already met
if you have read far enough into
the book,
who is a parody or model after
Dido.
But I just want to mention it,
because the Virgilian
background may suggest something
important about how Cervantes
conceived Don Quixote in his
second part.
Aeneas is known for his
prudence, for his sense of duty
from the very beginning,
when he carries Anchises on his
back as they leave a burning
Troy,
and when he repeatedly fends
off temptations,
Dido being the most memorable,
so that he can fulfill his
destiny,
which will be nothing less than
the founding of Rome.
Aeneas has the greatest excuse
for leaving a woman in the whole
of Western literature:
I've got to go found Rome!
Don Quixote cannot aspire to
such a grand design,
but Cervantes has given him a
different,
no less serious one,
and one that is consonant with
the age in which he lives,
which is no longer the heroic
age of Virgil's characters,
and that design is to conquer
himself.
This is going to be Don
Quixote's task.
The evolution of the mad Don
Quixote towards sanity and self
knowledge is the modern
equivalent of Aeneas' prudence
and task of founding the great
city.
This, it seems to me,
is the overall suggestion in
these repeated allusions direct
and indirect to Virgil.
Before, of course,
I spoke of Homer,
Ovid and Dante,
and about how Cervantes' field
of allusions and sources had
moved up from the romances of
chivalry to the core of the
western tradition,
without abandoning,
of course, the romances of
chivalry.
I also want to emphasize,
and I've already mentioned it,
that in these episodes that are
rewritings and in these major
episodes in Part II there is a
strong presence of death,
one way or another.
Sometimes, as in the pageant in
the forest, it is the very
figure of death as an
allegorical figure of death,
that you, I'm sure,
remember.
This is very much,
again, and I will be
emphasizing it today in one of
the episodes,
very much a part of the
Baroque.
Before I move on to some of the
truly outrageous episodes that I
want to discuss today,
let me say something about
Sancho's letter to his wife and
about the exchange of letters
that takes place in this section
of the novel.
Cervantes, who anticipated so
many things in the novel--
I think I've mentioned before
that García
Márquez,
the great Columbian writer said
that everything that novelist
could possibly want to do is
already in Cervantes--
but Cervantes in these
exchanges of letters is
anticipating epistolary fiction,
the letters to Teresa,
between Teresa and the countess
and so forth,
there are antecedents in
Spanish for epistolary fiction,
but here Cervantes,
in a modern,
already modern novel,
is anticipating that kind of
fiction.
The epistolary novel is one
which the whole novel consists
of an exchange of letters
between the characters.
As a genre, it became very
popular in the eighteenth
century,
as I'm sure you know,
in the works of authors such as
Samuel Richardson,
with his immensely successful
novels Pamela,
1740, and Clarissa, 1749.
In France there was the
Lettres persanes by
Montesquieu,
followed by Julie ou la
nouvelle
Héloïse,
by Jean Jacques Rousseau,
and Laclos,
a novel that I'm sure you have
read,
if not seen the movie,
Le Liaisons Dangereuses.
In Germany, Goethe,
The Sorrows of Young
Werther, and
Hölderlin's
Hyperion.
So, I mean, what Cervantes is
anticipating here was a very
popular genre in the next
century.
This exchange of letters in
the Quixote also reflects
a society in which writing has
become a crucial component of
life,
and communications--of life and
communications,
writing from printed documents
rival oral exchanges.
If you have been reading your
Elliott you will have learned
that this is a society obsessed
with documents,
mostly legal documents,
which is a class to which some
of the letters belong.
Letter writing is part of the
generation of the production of
legal documents,
so this is a reflection of
that, too.
It is also, here in the novel,
it is also writing within
writing,
and the epistles are documents
not processed into the fiction,
but presented raw,
as it were, meaning,
it doesn't say Sancho wrote to
Teresa saying this,
and that, and the other;
no, the document,
presumably as was dictated by
Sancho--of course,
he doesn't know how to
write--appears in the novel.
Modern fiction will expand on
this device.
I'm thinking here of Joyce,
of Dos Passos,
of Cortázar,
and other writers,
whose books contain documents,
such as these letters,
unabsorbed into the prose of
the fiction.
Now, Sancho's letter,
if we want to also look for the
antecedent in Part I,
is an echo of the one Don
Quixote wrote to Dulcinea and
that Sancho,
of course, forgot to take with
him and then memorized,
and we have all of those funny
episodes in which he tries to
retell it.
As in the first instance;
that is, as in that episode,
or those episodes,
the humorous--what is humorous
here--
is that both Sancho and his
wife, presumably,
are illiterate,
so this is an exchange of
letters between characters who
don't know how to read and
write.
The whole issue of the
production of the letter and the
duchess overseeing it and all of
that is part of the humor here,
as the production of the
letter, for Dulcinea was also
part of the humor in that
episode.
So now, we do move to these
outrageous episodes that I want
to discuss today,
and I'm sure when I mention
what they are you will see why I
use that adjective.
The first is the episode
involving the afflicted matron,
known as Countess Trifaldi and
Trifaldín of the White
Beard, her squire.
This is one of the wildest
inventions of the duke's
steward, and one of the
strangest in the whole Quixote
with no possible antecedent in
Part I.
That steward is described as
follows in page 705 of your
translation, by Jarvis.
It says, "The duke had a
steward,
of a very pleasant and
facetious wit,
who represented Merlin,
and contrived the whole
apparatus of the late adventure,
composed the verses,
and made the page act Dulcinea.
And now, with the duke and
duchess's leave,
he prepared another scene,
one of the pleasantest and
strangest contrivance
imaginable."
Unquote.
The steward is another internal
author, like Sansón
Carrasco, and Master Peter.
In fact, Sansón Carrasco
is one who scripts adventures
for Don Quixote,
does something that Master
Peter doesn't do,
but Master Peter is one of the
authors within the
Quixote.
So the steward not only
organizes the whole pageant,
but also writes the verses as
the quote says,
and plays the role of Merlin,
and then of Trifaldín.
He is as versatile as
Ginés de Pasamonte,
and even more.
He's a poet.
Now, internal authors,
like him and Sansón
Carrasco,
in the second part get to put
into action their creations,
as I have mentioned before,
and as you have seen,
the results are not exactly
what they planned,
but they do get to put them
into action.
The staging of his arrival as
Trifaldín is theatrical
and Baroque in the extreme.
Again, the intention is to
astonish both with the
elaborateness of the props,
and with their fearful
appearance and sounds or noises.
So they astonish with the act
of creation.
I mean, the creator of these
Baroque pranks is boasting of
his own ability,
and also astonish because of
the very nature,
size and noise.
If we go to page 708,709,
I will read the arrival of this
character:
"And, while they were thus
in suspense,
they perceived two men enter
the garden,
clad in mourning robes,
so long and extended,
that they trailed upon the
ground.
They came beating two great
drums, covered also with black.
By their side came the fife,
black and frightful like the
rest.
These three were followed by a
personage of gigantic stature,
not clad, but mantled about,
with a robe of the blackest
dye,
the train thereof was of
monstrous length.
This robe was girt about with a
broad black belt,
at which there hung an
immeasurable scimitar in a black
scabbard.
His face was covered with a
transparent black veil,
through which appeared a
prodigious long beard as white
as snow.
He marched to the sound of
drums, with much gravity and
composure.
In short, his huge bulk,
his stateliness,
his blackness,
and his attendants,
might very well surprise,
as they did,
all who beheld him,
and were not in the secret.
Thus he came,
with the state and appearance
aforesaid, and kneeled down
before the duke,
who, with the rest,
received him standing.
But the duke would in nowise
suffer him to speak,
till he rose up.
The monstrous spectre did so,
and, as soon as he was upon his
feet,
he lifted up his veil,
and exposed to view the
horridest,
the longest,
whitest and best furnished
beard,
that human eyes until then had
ever beheld;
and straight he sent forth is
broad and ample breast,
a voice grave and sonorous;
and, fixing his eyes on the
duke, he said..."
Of course, notice the
preponderance of black,
and notice that,
as in the pageant in the
forest, there are many
superlatives.
Everything is the largest,
the whitest,
the most horrible,
and the intention is to cause
admiration and fear on the
spectators.
Sancho dives into the duchess's
skirts the moment he sees this
apparition,
as he does whenever he's
afraid, when he's at the duke
and duchess's house,
he fainted in her arms in the
pageant in the forest.
And notice also the figure of
the monster;
I have spoken about the figure
of the monster before,
which is not only made up of
the most outrageous features,
but of contrasting one,
like the black dress and the
white beard.
The monster is a Baroque figure.
It does not have to be ugly,
just composed of clashing
features.
In Calderón de la Barca,
the playwright that I have
mentioned several times,
there are beautiful monsters,
namely beautiful women dressed
as men.
So don't confuse this figure of
the monster with the romantic
Frankenstein,
who is ugly,
repulsive and sort of a death
warmed over type,
but this is not the case with
these Baroque monsters.
The important thing in the
monster is the clash of
opposites;
the clashes between the two
genders, in the case of the
calderonian figures;
we saw that clash in the figure
of the Dulcinea of the pageant
in the forest.
Such figures are the opposite
of Renaissance harmony,
but they are,
however, announced in the
figure of Dorotea,
in Part I.
And, as in the cave of
Montesinos, and the pageant in
the forest,
we have a procession,
a parade of freaks,
and the sound of drums,
which mark the pace of the
whole ensemble.
In these theatrical shows the
characters don't walk,
they march.
Remember, in the cave of
Montesinos how all of these
eerie kind of women are marching
in a procession.
And, of course,
in the pageant in the forest we
have a huge procession,
parade, so there is no natural
motion such as walking;
it is marching to the beat of
the drums and the sounds of the
various instruments.
Now, the most remarkable thing
here, of course,
is the punishment,
within all of this fiction,
that the dueñas
have suffered.
The predicament of the
dueñas is again a
question of cross-dressing or of
cross-gendering.
Their mock affliction seems to
be an excess of testosterone
that provokes a wild growth of
facial hair.
Remember that they suddenly,
within this
fiction--boom!--have these
beards.
It is described in minute
detail how the hairs are
supposed to come out of the
pores and...
this is wild,
Cervantes at his wildest.
This is a hilarious condition,
and part of the mockery of
ladies-in-waiting of the whole
episode.
Sancho's diatribe against them
perhaps reflects an attitude of
the times.
Dueña Rodríguez,
from whom we will hear more
later, mounts a spirited
defense.
I'm using both
"duenna"
and "due&nti
lde;a,"
the Spanish is...
What is used in your
translation is the English
version "duenna."
Good old Sebastián de
Covarrubias, remember him?
The great lexicographer who
published in 1611 the Tesoro
de la lengua castellana and
that I warned you I would
mention several times during the
semester says the following in
my own translation defining the
"due&nti
lde;a."
I'm going through all of this
because I know that this is a
very strange figure for someone
in the twenty-first century.
It says: "In the old
Castilian languages [says good
old Sebastián]
it meant an old widowed lady.
Now, it generally means those
who serve wearing long nunish
gowns to distinguish them from
virgins.
And in the palaces
‘honored
dueñas' are
principle ladies who are widowed
and the queens and princesses
keep them near."
Unquote.
Meanwhile, Webster defines
lady-in-waiting as:
"A lady of rank who is a
member of the royal household
and in attendance of a queen or
princess."
I suppose--this is me now--I
suppose there is a sexual
connotation to this category of
women because they are
unattached or presumably
available,
but not young,
unmarried and virginal.
Why so many widows?
I mean, the death--people died
at a younger age in the
sixteenth and seventeenth
centuries,
and since men normally live a
shorter life than women,
even today, there are bound to
be a lot of widows around,
and, what do you do with these
widows?
Where do they go in society?
I guess some might go to the
nunnery,
"Go get thee to the
nunnery,"
remember Shakespeare,
but others are there in the
palaces;
they are of rank.
They are a bit like the
segundones,
the female counterpart of the
but they cannot quite go out
and start a career out at sea,
or the church,
so they are involved in
providing or facilitating sexual
encounters;
they're go-betweens,
they tend to be go-betweens,
as happens in the story
concocted by the steward.
I think that this is the
reason, this sexual sideline of
these widows.
There are all kinds of jokes
about widows and sexuality,
and all of that,
and throughout all traditions,
and this is why they are given
in jest a strong masculine
trait,
a beard, the opposite of the
role they're supposed to play,
which is very feminine,
in a sexual way.
So the last thing you would
expect them to have is a beard.
But also, you remember,
from my explanation of
Dulcinea's hair that,
you know, it meant also a
certain kind of sexuality.
So, hair, in the case of the
enchanted Dulcinea,
meant--remember the wench that
had the mole on her face,
with some hair,
that Don Quixote said she must
have another one on her thigh
with hair,
etcetera--it means sexual
proclivity,
being sexually hot.
These women are to be seen as
sexually active,
but only in a sexual way.
That is, they are not to be
loved and idealized,
they're only to be seen as
sexual, and this is why the joke
of having them grow hair.
Now, the story about the
Countess Trifaldi,
whom we
encountered--;remember--in
Spitzer's article.
Remember, the long discussion
by Spitzer about the Tri-faldi,
"tres faldas"
and all of that,
and how these names are made by
Cervantes.
The story about Countess
Trifaldi is very much like that
of Princess Micomicona in Part
I,
if you remember
that--Dorotea--except that it is
madly exaggerated.
There is a fantastic geography,
outrageously made up names;
it is a meta-meta fiction,
concocted by the characters of
the main fiction,
but here, in contrast to Part
I, the process is much more
premediated,
complicated,
and is played out as in a
theater,
not out on the road.
If you remember,
the priest and Dorotea make up
the story of Micomicona on the
go, and that's why she makes
mistakes.
Remember, the steward has taken
his time to compose this one,
it's a whole story very well
wrote, as it were.
Maguncia and Archipiela are the
deceased parents.
Maguncia--they are funny names;
I mean, the first is the German
town of Mainz,
which sounds very strange to
the Spanish ear:
Maguncia, Mainz,
in Germany;
and the second refers to
"archipelago"
a series of islands.
These names are geographic in
origin, because the story is
something of a geographic fable.
Candaya is another,
like el reino Micomicón,
is a made up kingdom.
But, of all of these names,
the funniest is
"Antonomasia,"
the young woman,
because it is the name that
takes the name of names.
It's a rhetorical figure,
it names,
Antonomasia,
it is a rhetorical figure to
name that which is the
quintessence of something,
the "Hercules,"
for a strong man is an
antonomasia,
The "Hitler,"
for an evil man,
is an antonomasia:
"From the Greek,
to call by another name the use
of an epithet of title,
instead of the proper name of a
person as when [I'm quoting
Webster]
when his honor is used for a
judge or when,
instead of Aristotle,
we say 'The Philosopher';
the use of a proper name,
instead of a common noun as
when an imminent orator is
called Demosthenes."
Unquote.
It is something like saying par
excellence, the quintessence of
something.
So why is she called
Antonomasia?
She is given the name of a
linguistic or rhetorical term
because she is made up of words:
she's a fiction within the
fiction made up by the steward,
so she's not to have the name
of a real person,
because she's made up of words.
This is what this name is
underlining.
Also, she's so named because
she and her story are
quintessential,
archetypal, common place.
Joaquín Casalduero,
whom I have mentioned before
several times--
Casalduero was a very prominent
hispanist in the forties and the
fifties;
he was impressed with German
criticism,
so he named all of his books
"Sentido y forma
de,"
'sense and meaning of,' Don
Quixote,
Celestina,
Novelas Ejemplares,
Sinn und Form it's derived from
German criticism,
but in spite of that,
he was a very good critic.
And I'm quoting from his book
called Sentido y forma del
Quixote, of course.
And he says:
"Don Quixote in his purity
launches forth to disenchant,
to save the lovers and the
dueñas to make
them recover their original
form.
He fights for the whole of
humanity, which is why the story
is filled with a sense of the
real.
Without alluding to anyone in
particular because all are
involved.
The name of the seduced young
woman is Antonomasia.
What he means is that
Antonomasia's name suggests that
Don Quixote fights for all
seduced and punished young
ladies."
And this is the sense of her
name, the prototypical one.
But, also, since the issue here
is,
one more time,
of marriage,
unequal marriage,
freedom, social status,
I think Cervantes,
with this name,
is perhaps poking fun at
himself,
for repeating the same story
under various guises throughout
the Quixote.
He's saying,
well, this one is Antonomasia,
is the prototypical of all of
the stories: Dorotea,
Marcela, and so forth,
that I have been telling and
I'm telling again,
so I'm making fun of myself by
giving her this very,
very funny name.
He may also be casting a
resigned and ironic glance at
human nature for always
repeating itself:
young women will always be
seduced by charming young men
and trouble will ensue.
This is what a name like
Antonomasia suggests,
too.
The rhetorical name also
reveals that his proxy,
his stand-in author,
the steward,
is a learned man.
It is, as if we called,
a literary character--
I've been thinking of what
other rhetorical name could we
give a literary character,
anaphora, for instance,
anaphora is the figure of
speech by which an orator
repeats over and again
something,
as in the case of the
assistant, of Master Peter's
assistant,
when he says,
"Look, look,
look," or when the
preacher says,
"Repent you sinners,"
and says it over and over
again;
that is anaphora.
I don't know if you agree,
you can come up perhaps with
even a better one.
Synesthesia,
you could call a literary
character.
These are also very good names
if you have a pet to name.
If you have a parrot that
repeats the same thing over and
over, you could call her
anaphora.
In any case, just a thought.
But it's very funny to have a
character called anaphora,
is supposed to be very funny;
it's a sophisticated joke.
I mean, not everybody knows
what Antonomasia means,
but it is supposed to be funny,
and it is.
Now, if in Part I we learned to
look for the story behind the
story,
in Part II we learned how a
story is made,
and the way that this steward
appears,
and the way that the story is
told,
and is presented,
and represented,
is a way of showing the inner
workings of the story,
so this is one way that we can
also contrast between the two
parts.
In Part I, we're looking for
the story behind the story of
what Cardenio said.
Here, we are shown the stage
props, the machinery,
the stage machinery through
which the story is being made.
Part of it is the name of this
character.
Now, so to sum up the story
made up by the steward,
Maguncia and Archipiela are the
parents of Princess Antonomasia,
impregnated by Don Clavijo,
a Don Juan type with the
connivance of Dueña
Trifaldi.
Notice that Clavijo is a
phallic name.
A "clavija"
is a peg, in a string
instrument.
Now, they have a little
mechanism with a screw type
thing,
but the old
"clavijas,"
the old pegs,
were simply stuck in by
pressure into the wood,
and hence, the name Clavijo is
a very phallic name;
another joke on the part of
Cervantes.
Now, Dueña Trifaldi is a
Celestina type.
Remember?
Celestina, the go-between,
1499, who arranges for their
encounters,
but she falls in love herself
with a young man,
which gives the story an
original twist,
a kind of sophisticated twist,
this older woman has fallen in
love with Clavijo,
who is a very charming guy,
who plays the guitar,
and all of that.
It is as if she vicariously had
the affair with Clavijo through
Antonomasia;
so there is a clever
sophistication involved in the
story here.
The steward is a very clever
author.
Now, Don Clavijo does marry
Antonomasia, as he had promised,
but the queen dies of grief
because of the disparity in
social class between them.
He is merely a knight;
he has the "don"
so he's a knight,
but she's a princess,
Antonomasia is the princess,
so Malambruno,
a giant and the queen's first
cousin,
who is the Pandafilando of this
story,
Malambruno, turns them into the
ornament atop a sarcophagus.
Now, if Pandafilando--remember,
was the pan-philanderer,
the one who had many affairs
with women,
pan philanderer,
Malambruno is a bad man:
from "mal,"
evil,
or bad, and "hombre,"
man,
or "hombruno," manly.
He's a bad man, Malambruno.
It's also a comical name.
In any case,
this is the gist of the story,
page 719:
"...upon the queen's
sepulchre appeared,
mounted on a wooden horse,
the giant,
Malambruno, her cousin-german,
who besides being cruel,
is an enchanter also.
This giant, in revenge for his
cousin's death,
and in chastisement of the
boldness of Don Clavijo,
and the folly of Antonomasia,
left them both enchanted by his
art,
upon the very sepulchre;
her converted into a monkey of
brass, and him into a fearful
crocodile, of an unknown metal;
and between them lies a plate
of metal likewise,
with letters engraved upon it
in the Syriac language,
which being rendered into
Candayan,
and now into Castilian,
contains this sentence:
'These two presumptuous lovers
shall not recover their pristine
form,
till the valorous Manchegan
shall enter into single combat
with me;
for the destinies reserve this
unheard-of adventure for his
great valour alone."
Unquote.
Notice the Baroque suffusing of
love with death.
The lover's likeness will lie
upon the tomb of the dead
mother, don't overlook that.
The steward author of the story
is learned as well as clever,
as we found in the pageant of
the forest,
with all of the Dante allusion,
and in his name of Antonomasia.
Here, he has contrived a truly
Baroque image in the
sarcophagus.
I have given you a handout.
On the one hand,
I could not resist having a
Doré drawing of the
dueñas,
as they are supposed to appear
in this episode,
but on the other I have a
series of sarcophagi,
because American tombs tend to
be very simple.
There is a headstone,
and then the tomb is just the
grass covering the body or the
casket;
there's something very
beautiful about it.
Dust will become dust,
and so forth,
and so on, but in the European
tradition,
in the continental tradition,
tombs tend to be much more
elaborate,
ornate and made of stone or
hard surfaces.
They are like little buildings;
there is a whole architecture
of tombs.
So, what is a sarcophagus?
Remember the etymology I gave
you when discussing the cave of
Montesinos episode,
"sarcos"
in Greek,
"flesh,"
and "phagein,"
"to eat,"
so the sarcophagus eats the
flesh of the dead body.
Sarcophagi were common among
the ancient Greeks and Romans,
you have some here.
It was a limestone coffin or
tomb often inscribed and
elaborately ornamented.
The point of the sarcophagus in
this story is the display and
the ornamentation,
which are the Baroque elements
as in the figure of the monster.
Remember that in Montesinos
cave the ornament on
Durandarte's sarcophagus was his
own cadaver.
The statute is made of flesh;
it was an inversion with nature
playing the role of art.
Here, we have a much more
elaborate kind of ornamentation.
How do we interpret the figures
of the monkey and the crocodile
here?
There are monkeys in Cervantes,
as we saw, with Micomicona,
and also the monkey that Master
Peter had with him.
As I said when mentioning those
episodes, they allude to
mimesis, to representation,
because they like to imitate
humans.
Here the ensemble could allude
to lust,
the croc eats the monkey,
as it were,
but both animals are,
the monkey and the crocodile,
are supposed to be demonic and
symbols of dissimulation,
of fakery.
This is why they grace the tomb
of these lovers.
Now, the story of Antonomasia
and Don Clavijo is one of
consummation and pregnancy.
I think that the pregnancy is
part of the Baroque grotesquerie
of the episode,
as is the interested
intervention of the
dueña.
What I mean by that is that
there is something grotesque
about the go between,
the older woman falling in love
with the young man,
and that the same kind of
grotesqueness is involved in the
pregnancy.
These contrasts,
you will find in the poetry,
for instance,
of Altisidora,
when she appears and sings a
song,
there will be sublime lines
followed by very vulgar ones.
And this is,
I think, the effect here of the
pregnancy.
Pregnancy would be unthinkable
in the stories of Part I
involving Dorotea,
Marcela, Lucinda or Zoraida,
although consummation did take
place with Dorotea.
But pregnancy literalizes lust,
removing idealizations about
love.
It underscores loves functional
biological drive to
reproduction.
Pregnancy is not very sublime.
It's not part of the courtly
love tradition.
It is unthinkable to imagine
Beatrice, Dante's beloved,
pregnant, or any of these
ladies.
So there will be another
pregnancy later,
involving Dueña
Rodriguez's daughter,
and we will discuss that
episode.
At this stage in the
Quixote we are well beyond
the idealized love of
Grisóstomo and Marcela or
of Don Quixote and Dulcinea.
Dulcinea has been enchanted
like a country wench.
So now we come to the end of
this adventure,
the end of this very well
wrought story that the steward
has composed,
and whose inner workings we are
observing as we read.
We move now to the episode of
Clavileño.
Clavileño has become
such an engrained name in the
Spanish tradition that there was
a very famous literary journal
in the thirties in Spain called
Clavileño.
Now, this story brings to a
close the story of the bearded
dueñas and the
disenchantment of Antonomasia
and Clavijo.
Now, first the chapter begins
with a mock tirade of self
praise on the part of Cervantes
about his narrative techniques
and characters,
page 720,721:
"In reality and truth,
all who delight in such
histories as this,
ought to be thankful to its
original author,
Cid Hamet, for his curious
exactness in recording the
minutest circumstances thereof,
without omitting anything how
trifling soever,
but bringing everything
distinctly to light.
He paints thoughts,
discovers imaginations,
answers the silent,
clears up doubts,
resolves arguments;
and, lastly,
manifests the least atoms of
the most inquisitive desire.
O most celebrated author!
O happy Don Quixote!
O famous Dulcinea!
O facetious Sancho Panza!
Live each jointly and severally
infinite ages,
for the general pleasure and
pastime of the living."
Now, this is very funny.
Cervantes is praising himself,
and he is praising himself by
anatomizing,
as it were, the props of his
own fiction or his own--
the make up of his own art.
What Cervantes is doing is
dismissing Aristotelian
injunctions concerning the
writing of history in this
passage.
According to the Philosopher,
to use an antonomasia to refer
to Aristotle,
history should not concern
itself with minutia,
but only with that which is
relevant to the grand
narratives,
which concern itself with major
historical figures,
not with characters of the ilk
Cervantes is dealing with,
nor should history dwell on
their thoughts,
except when expressed in highly
rhetorical speeches that are
presumed to express and display
their personalities.
Now, this is so against our
modern conceptions of history
that--
and Cervantes is already aware
of it--
because we do want details
about characters,
important and non-important
characters in history,
because we feel that in the
details you may find the truth,
not in this Renaissance
conception of history.
What I have just given you is
the core of the Renaissance
poetics of history,
but in this mock history that
Cervantes is writing it is
precisely the particular
details,
as well as the thoughts and
imaginings of the characters
that are of interest.
The remotest element of this
Renaissance poetics of history
is the question of the speeches,
because, of course,
there were no recording devices
at the time,
so when you hear a king deliver
an oration it is all made up by
the historian whose art involved
the creation of such speeches on
the part of these historical
characters,
that would reveal their
personality.
It was a way of delving into
their psychology.
Now, I know this is completely
against our notions of how to
write history,
but this is why Cervantes is
underlining it here.
He is interested in the
details, and he is interested in
the imaginings and the thoughts
of characters who are not that
important,
but are the characters who will
people the novel that he is
creating.
So, in other words,
this tirade shows that
Cervantes is increasingly aware
that he's creating a new kind of
writing,
which is derived from both
history and genres,
old and knew,
such as the epic,
the picaresque and the romances
of chivalry.
The tirade, by the way,
are to be presumed to be
uttered by the second author or
translator,
who frequently comments on Cide
Hamete's work,
a historian--remember--who's a
Moor given to prevarications.
So we have all of these folds
and layers of irony still
present.
But this is important,
because of what I said before,
as stories in Part II
displaying how they are made up.
So we move to Clavileño:
first the name of the horse.
It is derived from
"clavo,"
which means a "nail,"
but there is also an echo of
"clavija,"
the word that I used before,
that I mentioned before in
reference to Don Clavijo,
because the clavija
itself is derived from
clavo,
meaning something that is
stuck, and this alludes to the
steering peg,
or what is being a pilot would
call the yoke,
to steer this horse,
and
"leño,"
which means wood,
which is what the horse is made
of,
but
"leño"
or
"leña"
is a kind of wood used for
firewood, for burning.
The more noble wood used by
carpenters to make furniture or
cabinets is called
"madera."
Of course, Cervantes--it's too
unwieldy a word,
and also Cervantes is
underlining that this wood of
which Clavileño is made
is not of the noblest wood.
There is something demeaning to
"leño,"
Clavileño used to name
Clavileño.
I kept thinking what would be a
good translation into English or
a rendering,
I thought that the horse could
be called Firewood,
or he could be called--or I
think that the best would be
Woody.
I think, if we were to really
translate everything in the
book, Clavileño would be
called Woody,
as in Woody Woodpecker.
But Jarvis wisely sticks to
Clavileño;
he doesn't translate that,
but that's what the sense of it
is.
Now, the adventure of
Clavileño is derived from
several similar ones in romances
of chivalry,
so the parody of romances of
chivalry is carried out now not
so much by Don Quixote and his
actions,
but by the duke's servants,
particularly the steward.
He's not only learned and
clever, as I have been
emphasizing,
but he's also a reader of
romances of chivalry,
and, of course,
of the first of the
Quixote as well.
The motif of the flying horse
has a long tradition,
including Pegasus in Greek
mythology,
but the figure traveled long in
time in space after the Indian
and Persian versions,
he appears in the Arabic story
The Ebony Horse in The
Thousand and One Nights.
From there, it was disseminated
to France and Spain.
I won't give you the names of
the titles of some of these
romances in which appears,
but it is a figure that appears
fairly frequently.
So, obviously,
this reveals the steward's
knowledge of these romances of
chivalry.
Now, what is one of the
interesting features of the
flight is the all encompassing
view from above that the
characters have,
presumably have,
which is typical of the
Baroque,
the Baroque effort at all
inclusiveness,
which is now available with the
knowledge that the earth is
round and complete within
itself.
The episode has a great deal to
do with contemporary discoveries
about the infinite dimensions of
the cosmos,
about which I've spoken before,
and the inability of Ptolemaic
and Aristotelian cosmologist to
represent such a cosmos.
Don Quixote and Sancho believe
to be going through the spheres,
as described in the whole
cosmology,
and this, of course,
they encourage this by having
this fire next to their beards
or their faces;
so they figure they're going
through the sphere of fire,
and Sancho claims that he took
a stroll among the
constellations as they're
described in this old cosmology.
A corollary of the new
discoveries is that the world is
one and the same everywhere.
Sancho had introduced the topic
a few pages before,
when, upon hearing the story of
Antonomasia and Clavijo in
Candaya,
he says--page 718:
"What!
Are there court-alguazils,
poets, and roundelays in
Candaya too?
if so, I swear I think the
world is the same
everywhere."
Sancho thinks that the world is
the same everywhere,
and this I what the view from
above suggests.
Clavileño's flight in
the Quixote is the
co-relative opposite,
of course, of the cave of
Montesinos descent down,
up, no?.
Appropriately giving his
increasing importance,
it is now Sancho who tells the
story like the one Don Quixote
told after emerging from the
cave.
He speaks of a celestial flight
drawn from similar flights of
the spirit that are available in
Cicero,
Somnium Scipionis,
in Boethius,
The Consolation of
Philosophy, and even
in Fray Luis de León's
Still Night,
Noche Serena.
Fray Luis de León is
another great poet of the
sixteenth century that is
somewhere in the background
here.
As in other episodes,
in this second part Don Quixote
shows real courage before what
appears to be actual danger,
so does Sancho;
but they have played,
again, the role of objects of
the other's amusement.
So the Clavileño episode
is another prank,
another
"burla."
It's a word that I keep using,
"burla,"
prank,
at the expense of Don Quixote
and Sancho conceived and
executed by the duke's minions,
particularly, the steward.
All of these pranks are a
critique of mimesis,
in that they are literary or
theatrical acts of
representation which are
presented as pitiable attempts,
ultimately given up in favor of
humor.
These are attempts,
literary representation of
mimesis, and the wound up being
funny.
These, I think,
encapsulate Cervantes' own
effort in the Quixote.
They are dramatizations of his
plight, an answer to the problem
trying to represent reality,
coming up with a funny version
of it.
But there is something else,
too;
perhaps even more important in
these pranks and in the
Clavileño one,
in particular.
While it is true that Don
Quixote and Sancho are made fun
of and that they endure hardship
and danger when the whole
contraption blows up,
it is they who show courage and
determination,
and it is they who do fly in
their imaginations,
while the pranksters remain
earth bound,
some, like the duke and
duchess, astonished and even
frightened by the machinery that
they had constructed.
I think this sums up,
it seems to me,
Cervantes' attitude towards the
protagonist.
He may very well be ridiculous
in his efforts,
but his efforts have a certain
nobleness that others lack.
Just as he emerges unscathed
from the explosion and fall,
his dignity also remains
untouched.
In brief, Clavileño does
afford Don Quixote a flight at
once heroic and inspired.
As in the episode of the lions,
I repeat, he has demonstrated
his courage, even if the context
is not a heroic one.